[La musique]
une partie de l'europe ancienne et guerrière
a offert la terre quand le
enotri donne italo a pris le nom et a été
appeler l'Italie
c'est la terre
nous est destiné
[La musique]
notre histoire commence dans les pouilles a
il y a un million et demi d'années, lorsqu'un
primate du genre homo ébréché de
des roches vitreuses pour fabriquer les premiers outils
bifaces il y a 350 mille ans à caserta a
autre homme archaïque laissé sur la lave
volcanique les plus anciennes empreintes humaines
appelées empreintes du diable parce que
seul un démon pouvait marcher
sur de la lave encore chaude il y a 300 000 ans
les néandertaliens hominidés viennent
comportement social très avancé qui
ils s'installent en ligurie vénétie latium e
Pouilles où se trouve dal uomo di altamura
l'échantillon le plus ancien a été extrait
ADN de Néandertal
[La musique]
Il y a 50 000 ans d'Afrique
voici venir l'homo sapiens sapiens que oui
installés en europe sont appelés cro
magnon nos ancêtres directs le cro
magnon s'adapte aux ressources locales
chasser le renne bison vivre dans
huttes rondes qui protègent avec quelques
palissades et faire des décorations
de grottes reconnues comme les premières
chefs-d'œuvre du monde dans la péninsule
Les Italiens s'installent en Ligurie Emilie
romagne et molise où certains d'entre eux sont
ils rejoignent les néandertaliens avant eux
Ils disparaissent
dans les Pouilles il y a 30 000 ans
veine et broyez-le avec un ressort dans
pierre pour produire le premier pain de
monde il y a 18 mille ans dans les grottes de
addaura les premières incisions commencent
art rupestre dans le val camonica oui
produit la plus grande série de pedro
glyphes préhistoriques du monde et dans
grotte de l'ermite ainsi que le dessin
symboles sur la pierre tu travailles et oui
échanger de l'obsidienne contre un rocher
volcanique vitreux il y a 15 mille ans
en Vénétie, il est pratiqué avec succès le plus
ancienne chirurgie dentaire de la
monde en perçant les molaires avec une aiguille dans
le silicium il y a 10 000 ans est construit
l'une des plus anciennes villes du monde
toujours habité
matera avec ses maisons primitives et les
ses grottes creusées dans la roche
[La musique]
nous sommes à la fin de l'ère glaciaire
les eaux des mers la glace qui monte
de l'île à l'italie depuis l'europe fond
et en passant par les Alpes arrivent quelques
Les populations nomades indo-européennes avec
le climat tempéré arrive aussi par la mer
populations non indo-européennes les nouvelles
arrivé se sentir lisse et fondant
les indigènes construisent les premiers
villages fortifiés et forment les anciens
sociétés hiérarchisées avec des chefs de peuple
les hommes échangent des biens
ils pratiquent le culte de la fertilité
ils apprivoisent les béliers et les chiens se développent
l'agriculture pour laquelle ils cultivent le lin
faire des tissus produire de la poterie
travail en série du cuivre et de l'or à l'ancienne
centres métallurgiques et construire des dieux
temples mégalithiques pour calculer les cycles
de nature
à ce moment-là
L'Italie est divisée en quatre zones
culturel
la zone nord s'étendant de
Ligurie à la vallée du Pô et c'est
contrôlé par les Ligures
un peuple guerrier par culture
belliqueux la région de l'Adriatique que oui
s'étend du golfe de venise aux pouilles
et est contrôlée au nord par les Vénitiens et
ils gèrent le chemin de l'ambre qui vient
de la Baltique et au sud par les Messapiens
contraint au pas du corbeau
la zone tyrrhénienne comprend l'Italie
Corse occidentale, Sardaigne et
sicile où la culture de l'olivier
et la production de pétrole ne font plus qu'un
caractéristique de la cuisine et de la
Paysage italien
enfin dans la zone ionienne en Calabre oui
extrait un métal qui est travaillé en cuivre
permet la fabrication d'outils
plus spécialisés que ceux
fabriqué dans la pierre, le cuivre est d'un grand intérêt
aux belliqueux Ligures qui le trouvent dans
la ligurie et lu travaillent dans les plus anciens
mines et bassin de cuivre
méditerranéen
l'utiliser pour produire des armes avec
qui défendent leurs routes
commercial
[La musique]
aujourd'hui la plus vieille momie du monde était
doté d'un équipement ingénieux en
cuivre qui lui permettait de transporter
les braises pendant de longues heures en haute montagne
il y a 3500 ans avec un alliage de cuivre et
l'étain est obtenu le bronze plus dur de
cuivre et cela permet aux communautés qui
ils l'utilisent pour l'emporter sur eux
encore équipé de pierres et de cuivre
le bronze à un grand succès le
le lingot de bronze devient un moyen de
paiement et avec l'invention de l'épée
les premiers grands peuples européens émergent
aussi libre dans la péninsule ibérique
hitachi dans les carpates et les mycéniens dans
Grèce mais quand les Hittites du
la mésopotamie enseigne aux tribus barbares
des taureaux pour travailler le fer pour les faire
d'armes ceux-ci envahissent la péninsule
Grec et anéantir les Mycéniens armés
seul le bronze en Italie est le fer
d'abord utilisé par les Étrusques un
population émergente installée en emilie en
Toscane où il établit les premiers royaumes
de la péninsule avec l'âge du fer
les grandes invasions commencent à venir
de Grèce et des balkans où ils arrivent
Italie d'autres peuples tels que sûr je
échouer les latinos
les œnotriens
les vignerons menés par leur légendaire
Les rois italiens envahissent les Pouilles la
basilicate calabre et sicile
mais quand ils essaient de conquérir le
La Toscane, les Marches et la Ligurie sont
repoussés vers le sud par les Étrusques et par les
libre
les enotri sont ensuite installés dans le
calabre du sud où italo a fondé le
son capital d'acres fonde l'ancien
lois et instituts banquets
communautés de rituels politiques
partage religieux et amitié
caractérisé par le repas commun de
nom italien les belles terres de
catanzaro s'appellent l'italie et le
les gens de l'enotri prennent le nom de
Eataly l'utilisation du fer permet une
nouveaux peuples européens tels que les Allemands je
Bretons les Grecs et les Celtes à conquérir
autres terres
les Celtes un peuple indo-européen
venant du danube envahissent le
Piémont et la vallée du Pô où
ils ont trouvé le médiolanum milan d'aujourd'hui
les sépultures de ces derniers témoignent
un art très fin et leur culte
prêché par les druides est celui de
transmigration de l'âme les grands
les invasions continuent avec les Grecs qui
après s'être libéré des Doriens
conquis les côtes sud
où ils ont trouvé de nombreuses villes telles que
ancône reggio calabre naples tarente
Croton Syracuse et Messine
[La musique]
les Grecs sont aussi porteurs de nouveaux
institutions politiques telles que la démocratie
[La musique]
dans la splendeur de leurs colonies
Les Italiens connus sous le nom de magna greece vivent
artistes philosophes et scientifiques grecs tels que
Pythagore autochtone comme Archimède
[La musique]
les invasions continuent avec les Phéniciens qui
ils chassent les grecs de libye e
coloniser les côtes nord
d'Afrique où ils forment le peuple de
Carthaginois à partir du présent
tunisie les carthaginois conquièrent le
terres et des dieux libres, mais quand ils essaient de
envahir les îles italiennes sont rejetées
en sicile des grecs en sardaigne en
corse par les Sardes appelé sardano il
peuple légendaire de la mer aussi je
les colverts migrent en envahissant en masse à
terres et les Celtes leur poussée et ainsi de suite
impoli que certains peuples celtiques fuient
vers les terres des Bretons l'autre vers
la péninsule ibérique et les terres des
Les Étrusques et autres sont poussés à l'intérieur
cage
les Celtes s'installent en Gaule
appelés coqs sont célèbres pour leur
chevalerie guerrière et effectuer quelques
raids partout
les coqs menés par brennus pillent
aussi rome
à l'époque une citadelle fondée en
753 avant JC par Romulus II
légendaire premier roi de rome
la citadelle est née de l'unification de
divers enseignements indépendants qui ont surgi sur le
mont palatin qui est alors
entouré de murs pour former la ville
place de la maison des rois romains rome
il devient un véritable centre urbain en regroupant
les colonies qui partent de la colline
esquilin à la colline du quirinal
puis s'étendant le long du Tibre jusqu'au
mer d'ostie
[La musique]
mais cette bande de mer est contrôlée
des Étrusques c commencer une série de
guerres contre les romains guerres qui
ils continuent même lorsque Tarquinius Priscus
un réfugié étrusque à Rome vient
valorisé au point d'être élu
cinquième roi de rome avec tarquinio priscus
est fait lorsque le trou est récupéré
Centre politique religieux romain e
l'administration de la ville ainsi que
travaux publics importants tels que les temples
le cirque maximus
le premier édifice romain pour les spectacles
il est suivi de deux autres rois trousse chi
mais les romains ne perdent jamais les leurs
composante culturelle ethnique latine et oui
libéré des rois en proclamant le
république
[La musique]
cependant les inégalités sociales entre
patriciens et plébéiens provoquent de graves conflits
intérieur
c'est la situation à rome quand
est pillé par les Gaulois mais les Romains
ils n'oublient pas et veulent se venger
se protéger des invasions
ils construisent la grande muraille
serviane reconstitue rapidement le
ville et construire les premières routes
postes consulaires et les premiers aqueducs oi
ils forment une armée bien entraînée
ils éliminent les Étrusques qu'ils soumettent
tous les peuples italiens
ils admettent la magna grèce
et envahir le nord de l'Italie
ils appellent gallia cisalpina alarmé
de l'avancée romaine les Gaulois soutiennent
L'invasion des Carthaginois par Hannibal
mais la république romaine
bien qu'attaqué sur ses propres terres, il est
devenir une véritable machine de guerre
les contre-attaques battent les troupes d'Hannibal
et effacer Carthage pour toujours
occupe alors la péninsule ibérique et la
la grèce s'arrêtant d'un air menaçant à
bords de la cage
les coqs et les humains comme les Grecs de Marseille
ils préfèrent s'allier à rome plutôt
que de le combattre
les coqs sur le yen forment plutôt un
coalition et attaque marseille qui
demande de l'aide aux Romains
Rome n'attendait rien d'autre
ses légions passent le rythme des Alpes
la coalition gauloise libère Marseille
et sur les territoires subjugués ils trouvèrent
La Gaule narbonnaise quand les Allemands lèvent
lourd envahir la Gaule en le poussant
celti albè trv coqs et duels aussi
ils demandent l'aide des alliés romains rome
le proconsul Julius intervient à nouveau
César est chargé de la mission de
chef de ses légions César en trois
gallian et bat à la fois le suisse sur
lourd puis s'installe dans les terres
conquis et propose aux coqs de rejoindre
à la république romaine pour s'opposer
avec les incursions des Allemands
les coqs refusent et appellent à l'aide je
Les Belges des Celtes se sont germanisés mais César est
invincible bat aussi les Belges et
profiter des différences entre les coqs
conquérir toute la Gaule
appeler la Gaule transalpine
s'inquiéter de la permanence de
Les troupes romaines et leurs territoires
les coqs mettent leurs désaccords de côté
et s'unissent pour faire face
l'ennemi commun
[La musique]
le commandement de la coalition est confié à
vercingétorix un jeune chef à berne
dans les premiers combats césar a vaincu ma
marché brûle les terres des Gaulois et
assiégeant Vercingétorix en Asie
met fin à la rébellion césar écrit
dans ses commentaires sur la guerre des Gaules
avoir triomphé de la terreur gauloise avec moi
mais à son retour à rome césar e
assassiné
commence alors un terrible combat pour la
puissance se terminant quand octave
auguste neveu de césar me bat
conspira et fut fait empereur
Ainsi l'Empire romain est né du Sénat
[La musique]
la pax romana est une paix armée mais rome
mène à la culture et à l'écriture note i
pays occupés avec de grandes infrastructures
et sa supériorité militaire permet
au commerce de se développer tout au long
calme
rome poursuit ses conquêtes
sur l'île britannique et admet les terres
de données en étendant son domaine jusqu'à
au golfe Persique
mais les invasions des Mongols un ed
Les Iraniens bouleversent les frontières
de l'Empire romain dévastant tout al
leur passage
les Huns pénètrent les terres des dieux
Les Allemands poussent les Goths vers la mer
noir et francs il a les mains dans
cage
rome réagit bat les francs
les confinant au nord de la Gaule
transalpina et bat aussi les mères
les repoussant vers le rhin mais le
la situation n'est plus contrôlable
trop étendu pour être bien défendu
l'empire romain est divisé en deux
l'Empire romain d'Occident avec capitale
milan depuis que rome est devenu un centre
La religion chrétienne et l'Empire romain
d'Orient avec capitale byzantine
l'istanbul actuelle mais l'empire romain
de l'Occident affaibli par les invasions
les barbares doivent céder l'île
Britanniques les Allemands Ang Lee et les Saxons
ils lui donnent le nom d'Angleterre
[La musique]
au nord la pression des Huns de
attila ne laisse pas de répit à son allemagne
loin les vandales chassés en Gaule
ils la traversent pour s'installer en espagne
et en afrique pendant que j'y étais je t'odoacre
poussé en Italie, il ne la pille pas
déposer le dernier empereur romain
de l'ouest pour rome symbole de
le christianisme est le loyer mais byzance oui
oppose des matches prestigieux
les gens des goths qui passent par son
empire et lui confie la tâche de libérer
Rome en retour lui promet des dieux
territoires en cage
les goths démissionnent donc mars et
ils ont battu les earlys puis se sont séparés en deux
peuples
les Wisigoths qui chassent définitivement
les huns pour ensuite installer dans
l'aquitaine et les envahisseurs Ostrogoths
L'Italie désobéissant aux ordres de
Byzance
occupé par des barbares sans empereur e
avec l'armée en déroute
l'empire romain d'occident doit
abandonner également la péninsule ibérique e
la Gaule de ce profite clovis
le jeune roi des Germains francs qui
repousse les Wisigoths en Espagne et envahit
cage lui donnant le nom de france lo
dû et païen mais conscient de la force
de l'union de l'église se fait un
baptiser un chrétien en obtenant le titre
d'auguste par le pape et la couronne de
Empereur romain d'Occident de
byzance c'est quoi la merde aux ostrogoths
d'Italie
[La musique]
la capitale de l'empire romain byzance
de l'est aussi appelé empire
Byzantine règne sur la culture grecque
l'empereur justinien instaure le
bases de la législature en cours
les lois et l'égalité des droits pour tous sauf
byzance doit céder le nord de l'italie
aux Allemands lombards et défendre la
propre empire des musulmans qui
ils avancent vers les Balkans arrêtés par
Bulgares un peuple des steppes et direct
sur le danube les musulmans
puis ils traversent l'afrique ils l'envahissent
péninsule ibérique et anéantir les Wisigoths
Les musulmans essaient aussi de conquérir
France mais dans la célèbre bataille de
poitiers est battu par charles hammer
qui les rejette en Espagne
[La musique]
à cette époque la france est dominée par
vassaux plus puissants du roi et de charles
marteau fondateur de la dynastie des
Les Carolingiens sont les plus puissants des vassaux
francs
à tel point que son fils Pippin le court
destitue le roi légitime si de rigo
troisième et se proclame roi des Francs
mais sa couronne n'est pas légitime pour
pour devenir on a besoin de l'église
car ce sont les papes qui couronnent le roi
les chrétiens
[La musique]
l'occasion se présente lorsque les païens
Les Lombards envahissent Rome père Stefano
la seconde demande de l'aide à Pippin le court
qui entre alors en Italie bat moi
Lombards et reçoit en récompense le
couronne du seul et légitime roi du
francs à son apogée pitino chasse
derniers musulmans à vapeur france en e
regagner le leadership rya qui était
rendu indépendant laissant à lui-même
fils charlemagne et charlemagne un royaume
franche étendue et puissante quand
charlemagne meurt charlemagne oui
prend possession des territoires du frère e
roi guerrier chassant les musulmans dal
Le nord de l'Espagne bat alors
définitivement l'annexe des Lombards i
Pays germaniques et repousse les Byzantins
Dans le sud de l'Italie
se plaçant enfin en protecteur de
église
charlemagne donne au pape léon iii la
la corse et le centre de la presqu'île
italien lui permettant de fonder
État pontifical où les papes pourront
régner avec des pouvoirs temporels tels que moi
dirigeants
lion iii le récompense en encerclant sa tête
avec la couronne de fer sacrée qui
la légende l'a forgé avec des clous
de la croix du Christ et le consacre
empereur des romains avec tous
magnificence et les titres de l'ancien
Rome
[La musique]
pendant ce temps le nord et le sud et l'italie
fragmenter en petits états rivaux i
Les Byzantins perdent la Sardaigne et les ducats
cloches qui acquièrent une autonomie e
Je pardonne aussi la Sicile conquise par les
Pirates sarrasins
[La musique]